[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo la concentración de tropas
rusas en la frontera con ucrania ha
hecho despertar los temores sobre una
nueva invasión de moscú a su vecino y
sobre todo ha hecho correr ríos de tinta
sobre el tema especialmente desde
estados unidos en los países de
occidente para rusia estas alertas no
son más que ataques de pánico empezamos
el temor ante una eventual invasión de
rusia a ucrania sigue latente y va en
aumento desde noviembre de 2000 21
cuando eeuu hizo sonar las alarmas sobre
una gran concentración de soldados rusos
en la frontera con su vecino y aunque
mosco ha descartado insistentemente un
ataque los antecedentes sobre la anexión
de crimea en 2014 no ofrecen garantías y
aunque este tema es abordado desde todos
los ángulos de medios de comunicación de
eeuu en los países de la unión europea
en rusia la historia es otra echemos un
vistazo
remontémonos al 11 de febrero de 2022
cuando eeuu advirtió sobre un inminente
ataque a ucrania así se encontraba la
página principal y algunos de los medios
más importantes de eeuu europa ésta era
la noticia principal en portales como
the washington post además resaltaba el
llamado del gobierno estadounidense a
sus ciudadanos para que abandonaran la
ex república soviética también lo hacía
el 'new york times' en europa así lo
registraba el diario francés le monde
the guardian del reino unido- resaltaba
que sería dentro de unos días en
alemania el semanario alemán 'der
spiegel' citaba fuentes oficiales que
pronosticaban un ataque para el 16 de
febrero y así también lo titulaba el
periódico estadounidense político
la fecha en la que se esperaba el
presunto ataque llegó y nada sucedió
esto trajo burlas de las autoridades
rusas que han calificado los reportes de
los medios como histeria esto dijo a
través de su cuenta de telegram la
portavoz del ministerio ruso de
exteriores
les pido a los medios de desinformación
de eeuu y el reino unido- como bloomberg
the new york times' de song y otros que
publiquen el calendario de nuestras
invasiones para el año próximo para que
pueda planificar mis vacaciones mientras
occidente alertaba sobre la posible
fecha de invasión en rusia la historia
era otra el periódico nóvaya gazeta
informaba sobre la condena contra un
adolescente acusado de querer atentar
contra un edificio federal en el popular
videojuego minecraft izvestia tenía las
denuncias del portavoz del kremlin quien
dijo que no obtuvo respuesta de la otan
a preguntas formuladas por el presidente
vladimir putin con somos calla prada
informaba sobre la muerte de un niño de
6 años atropellado por un tren y el
diario kommersant tenía en su página
principal la intención de rusia de
castigar a eeuu por no emitir visas a
diplomáticos rusos en la onu mientras
que en un apartado más pequeño la
noticia sobre el reino unido- instando a
sus ciudadanos a abandonar a ucrania y
una advertencia de la casa blanca sobre
una eventual invasión durante los juegos
olímpicos
durante una reunión con periodistas
internacionales el presidente de ucrania
volodymyr selenski dijo que cuando lee
medios internacionales se siente como si
hubiera tanques en las calles de ucrania
y por ello invito a la prensa a visitar
kiev y presenciar la situación escucha
la sensación que están dando los medios
es que tenemos una guerra que tenemos
tropas en las carreteras movilización
militar que la gente se está yendo no es
así no necesitamos este pánico carne
patricia chapoy y en medio de estos
reportes de ambas partes cuál es la
percepción de los ucranianos se lo
preguntamos a alexander sleeps y
analista político en kiev ucrania nos
acostumbramos a vivir a vivir en tal
condiciones porque de verdad la guerra
durante este 2014 no es un secreto el
estado está siempre comunicando con la
población que si eso fuera algo puede
pasar
estamos preparados estamos listos pero
si a eso puede pasar para que preparar a
la gente
y
eliminar esas cosas de sorpresa que se
ataque por sorpresa pues
el estado los medios de comunicación
están en el mixto en tiempo
intenten a un poco tranquilizar la gente
para quién no
y provocar el pánico otra vez porque eso
es muy importante para que la ciudad sea
preparada en nuestro plan y por supuesto
el temor ante la eventual invasión
también ha sido discutido en redes
sociales dando lugar a noticias falsas
a continuación desmentiremos algunas de
las que más han circulado en las
plataformas cientos de usuarios en
twitter y facebook compartieron las
imágenes de esta joven que porta lo que
parece ser un rifle en el transporte
público y en el encabezado de la
publicación menciona que así es la vida
ahora en ucrania hicimos una búsqueda de
la fotografía en google imágenes y vimos
que ha circulado en internet antes de
que estallaran las nuevas tensiones y
aunque no pudimos identificar cuál es el
contexto de la imagen notamos que fue
compartida hace dos años en la
plataforma red it allí se menciona que
la chica está en un tren en belarús es
por ello que tales afirmaciones son
falsas
otra serie de publicaciones en twitter
muestran una captura de pantalla que usa
el logo de la cadena cnn y en su titular
se lee una noticia de última hora
anunciando que según fuentes el
presidente ruso vladimir putin decidió
retrasar la invasión hasta que eeuu
entregue armas a ucrania para poder
quitarse las hicimos la misma búsqueda
en google imágenes y encontramos un link
que nos llevó a una noticia de cnn con
fecha de 2017 y al final del artículo
encontramos el vídeo original del que
fue tomada la captura en la pantalla en
realidad se lee una cita del presidente
putin en la que niega haber interferido
en las elecciones de eeuu también
descubrimos que la misma imagen se
alteró en 2018 para afirmar falsamente
que el mandatario había cancelado el
mundial de fútbol que se celebró en su
país así que este contenido también es
falso
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir esta u otra misión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www france24
puntocom
[Música]